today on the matt well show as the kyle
rittenhouse case heads to trial next
week we'll talk about the people who
should really be standing trial for
everything that happened in kenosha last
summer also the daily wire breaks major
news that could be the nail in the
mcauliffe campaign's coffin and more
damning information has come out about
the armorer on the set of that alec
baldwin movie was this a diversity hire
gone wrong plus an instagram influencer
poses for selfies next to her father's
coffin and in our daily cancellation i'm
afraid i must cancel
many of you in the audience i don't want
to do it but i have no choice
all of that and much more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
as we survey the scorched and barren
landscape of the of america cirque circa
2021 you may arrive at the conclusion
that the people running this show have
done you know less than a stellar job
you may even say that president biden
though still very early in his tenure
is already making a run for the title of
worst president ever he presents a
compelling case for himself gas prices
are skyrocketing grocery store shelves
are empty our cities are gripped by
historic levels of violence and crime
the fbi terrorizes parents at school
board meetings
our military worries about diversity and
inclusion
and the state department celebrates
pronouns day while china strengthens its
empire across the globe and although
biden promised to
assume office and shut down the
coronavirus it has in fact killed more
people under his watch than it did under
trump all of this and we haven't even
mentioned the 13 u.s service members
killed in afghanistan
all of it would seem to add up to if not
the worst first year in presidential
history
certainly very close to the top of the
list in the conversation for the title
but then again
in the interest of balance and fairness
we must acknowledge joe biden's one
achievement and it's a major one
incredibly although he is a barely
sentient lump of plato biden has still
managed somehow to achieve one historic
feat
and that is that he solved systemic
racism
you might not have noticed
but he did it's a pretty big deal
i would hope you would agree admittedly
you know i have no direct evidence that
biden solved systemic racism or even
that there was any systemic reason
racism to solve in the first place but
there's a very good circumstantial case
that can be made consider this in
trump's tenure mostly during the
election season coincidentally
every police shooting of a black suspect
was the result of racism which is why it
was necessary for blm to riot
continuously for six months every
shooting was a big deal you might recall
it was a major topic of conversation it
was all the media focused on for months
and then amazingly
almost miraculously
joe biden took office in january of this
year
and ever since then there has not been
one blm riot
nobody is talking about police shootings
anymore
it's not because there haven't been any
the numbers this year are about what
they were last year but apparently it
would seem that none of these shootings
are racism related every shooting under
trump during the campaign was racism
none of them under biden or racism
wow either that or blm stopped caring
about racism entirely either that or the
whole police brutality panic was always
a political ploy and blm or a bunch of
evil underhanded duplicitous fraudulent
race hustling hacks
you know those are kind of the us and on
second thought maybe that third option
might be the right one in any case
memories of those um ancient days are
now coming back to the surface as the
trial of kyle rittenhouse is set to
commence next week ridden house is of
course the young man who shot three
attackers two fatally during the riots
in kenosha in the summer of 2020 back
when systemic racism existed
it's relevant to note that those riots
were sparked ostensibly
by the shooting of jacob blake by
officer rustin chesky
blake was shot after accosting a woman
who had previously allegedly raped and
then fighting with police while armed
with a knife and finally trying to climb
into a car that was not his while
children were sitting in the back seat
officer officer chesky was cleared by
local prosecutors and
by biden's doj
the latter was announced just a few
weeks ago with little notice paid to it
did you even hear about that
even biden's doj
couldn't find any charges to hang on
chesky and not for lack of trying
but he was so you know his actions were
so utterly and unassailably justified
and blake was so clearly the bad guy and
the aggressor in the situation that even
the people over at the doj under biden
couldn't find anything to do with this
case other than let it quietly go away
be that as it may riots broke out or
rather continued and ridden house who
arrived on the scene to try and help
protect property owners from the rampant
destruction being visited upon them by
the unchecked mob eventually was forced
to use his weapon in self-defense and it
was indeed self-defense
okay it was not just in fact it was not
just self-defense
but it was one of the clearest cut cases
of self-defense that you will ever see
on film that's not an exaggeration
video footage proves incontrovertibly
that rittenhouse was being pursued
attacked
by violent mobs who had made their
intentions clear both by word and
deed rin house can be seen trying first
to flee
and only resorting to deadly force when
he had no other choice
to say that it was not self-defense is
to say that rittenhouse had a legal
obligation to submit himself to the mob
trusting i guess that they'll only beat
him severely and not go beyond that
in fact the case against rittenhouse is
so flimsy
that the prosecutors themselves
while trying to make the case against
him can't help but accidentally
vindicate him
so yesterday in a pre-trial hearing
kenosha county circuit court judge bruce
schroeder
ruled that prosecutors may not refer to
the dead rioters as victims and this has
led to a major temper tantrum among
leftists online as you can imagine
but the ruling makes sense to call them
victims is to assume that they were
murdered
but murder is what the prosecution must
prove so it can't be assumed ahead of
time
yet the judge will allow and the left
they you know they love this detail even
more the judge will allow the defense to
call the dead rioters rioters and
looters and arsonists
though only during closing arguments if
they present evidence that the labels
are accurate which they are
here is the prosecution protesting this
this decision and explaining um
you know
why they have a problem with it
but listen to what
is actually being said here listen
what i'm hearing the defense say is for
example mr rosenbaum started fires that
night
well that has nothing to do with the
allegation that he chased after mr
rittenhouse and tried to physically
attack him
arsonist or alleged arson has nothing to
do with an alleged physical assault
there is an argument that mr rosenbaum
was
shouting
racial slurs that has nothing to do with
the physical assault
there's an allegation that he's telling
other people at ultimate gas station to
shoot him
which
clearly is different than what was going
on with mr rittenhouse
he clearly didn't want mr ringhaus to
shoot him so i don't see that there's
any commonality there so this is
this is bad character evidence your
honor this is an attempt to tell the
jury mr rosenbaum's a bad guy and
deserve to die that's really what it is
he was an arsonist he was a rioter he
was starting fights or was not starting
fights he was starting problems he was
disorderly he was loud he was uh
whatever therefore
he was it was okay for the defendant to
kill
that's really what's going on here your
honor and that's not at all what 90404
allows
yeah well the prosecutor really laid
that out well didn't he i mean
one of the quote-unquote victims
rosenbaum
was an out-of-control violent rioter who
did pursue kyle ridden house did try to
whip up a mob
and by the way he was also a sex
offender charged with molesting a minor
many of these facts are directly
relevant and the rest are indirectly
relevant because they establish what
sort of man
this quote unquote victim was which
lends more credence to rittenhouse's
version
of events though the most credence comes
from the video footage which is again
already decisive and exculpatory
you'll notice that the mindless hordes
calling for written house's head
they don't have any interest in talking
about the actual events of that night
because they know that the events
themselves absolve the defendant of any
wrongdoing instead they say that ridden
house shouldn't have been there in the
first place
and they make a big deal about the fact
that he crossed state lines
every post you see from you know someone
on that side of this online about the
written house every single one in in all
capsules he crossed state lines he
crossed state lines well so what
what they don't mention is that the kid
worked in kenosha
it's not as though he traveled hundreds
of miles by plane train and automobile
to get there even if he did i'm not sure
i see what the relevance would be
but he worked in the community he was
very much a community member
earlier he had been helping clean up
clean up graffiti he was more
he was more of a community member and
more involved and more concerned about
his community than any of those rioters
hands down
so he belonged there as much as anybody
else on the street that night
though you might say that none of them
belong there
because none of it should have happened
and on that point you'd be correct
kyle rittenhouse should not have felt
the need to patrol the street with a gun
not because there was no need but
because there should not have been a
need
the blm mobs never should have been
allowed to reign terror and destruction
for weeks and months on end
in response to a police shooting
that was completely justified
the police should have done their jobs
they should have been allowed to do
their jobs
those in charge of establishing and
enforcing law and order should have done
so
they're the ones to blame for all this
ultimately so if anyone should be on
trial in the kyle rittenhouse case it
shouldn't be kyle rittenhouse it should
be the mayor of kenosha
and the governor of wisconsin they ought
to be standing there in chains facing a
lifetime in prison for handing their
city over to thugs and looters
and abandoning their citizens to the
violence and chaos that inevitably
ridden
followed
went to kenosha that night
to do what they would not do
he was attacked and had to defend
himself in the process making him a
victim in this story
and now his victimhood is compounded by
this politically motivated show trial
so in the end you know you might say
that the left is correct
that it will be an outrage if kyle
rittenhouse just walks away from all
this a free man
because he should walk away a free and
rich man after suing for malicious
prosecution
that would be
true justice in this case
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
okay we i just want to show this uh
quickly before we get to the headlines
uh right at the top here because it is
pretty outrageous uh biba
adams who's a reporter
brings this to our attention let's pull
up the tweet
so she was at walmart
and she uh here it is she says this is a
toy tank
like for kids to ride in who the f wants
to buy kids a tank never mind i know who
and yes this is walmart and then she
she censors the word walmart which is a
vulgarity now i suppose
so uh so she it's it's this giant toy
tank
that i guess is that kids can ride in
and i have to say this is terrible i am
i am stunned
it makes me sick with anger
because why didn't they have something
like this when i was a kid why didn't we
have toys as cool as this
um it drives me crazy i'm fuming over it
every time i go to the toy section
to get my kids a toy i'm looking around
i'm getting i'm getting mad because
where was all this stuff when i was a
kid
apparently that that thing actually
fires nerf balls as well so it's kind of
functional which is awesome
i'll tell you my one objection to toys
like this this is my only one um
it's not that it encourages violence or
whatever
it is uh
it is
as a parent
that that's the kind of thing you get
for your kid and it's awesome and it's
amazing and you would have loved it when
you were a kid and you get it and you
give it to them and they're super
excited
and they use it once and they love it
and they're thrilled and they never use
it again
that's that's the way that always
goes i've how many just every single
holiday as as a parent you go through
this
in fact just last year i got my kids
this it wasn't as cool as the tank but i
got them this really this really neat
and this is how i sold it to him i said
this is really neat guys a really neat
remote control card i had remote control
cars when i was a kid but this thing was
it was like top speeds it would go like
60 miles an hour that's probably an
exaggeration but it would go really fast
it could go on any terrain it could flip
over and keep going
it had little lasers and lights they
could play music it was the coolest
thing
and i take them outside you know and
first i'm playing with remote control
first just to make sure it's safe you
know i i said i got to play with it for
10 minutes just to make sure it doesn't
explode or anything i just want to make
sure it's safe
and it's the coolest thing ever
and um
you know then my sons are playing with
it a little bit and then they run off
to the woods and they come back
and they say daddy look look what we
found a really pointy stick and they
have a pointy stick and then that's what
they play with they don't care about the
remote control car anymore so
that's my problem with the tank but
other than that
that is uh i want to thank biba adams
for pointing us in that direction
um
maybe they make them for adults i guess
that would just be a regular tank
so here's what um
let's talk about virginia in the
campaign
let's we'll start with this here's what
terry mcauliffe
was doing last night
and i'm going to make you watch this as
punishment
it's really punishment for watching my
show rather than just listening to it
like a normal podcast listener so here
he is with with joe biden let's play
this
um there he is dancing
yeah this is penance that you have to
watch that
it's penance for the audience don't play
play it one more time make them watch it
again
look at those moves
[Music]
he's like your drunk creepy uncle
trying to hula hoop or something
look if you can't dance then then don't
all right especially not on this is the
kind of
arrogance
that these people have
in the bubble that they've lived in
because this is not the first time that
terry mccullough has done this he gets
on on stages and dances all the time
nobody's ever sat him down and said
listen terry this is awful you're
traumatizing people will you stop it
every time you dance you drop five
points in the polls
nobody tells them
um i think probably bigger news though
from terry mcauliffe
is uh this exclusive from the daily wire
it says a law firm that employed
virginia gubernatorial candidate terry
mcauliffe has made a cottage industry
out of aggressively fighting victims of
alleged sexual abuse in schools being
paid handsomely to defend school systems
that the girls say failed to protect
them
in one case
the hunton andrews kurth law firm where
mcauliffe served as a senior advisor
from 2019 recently is battling a young
woman who says that and this is
horrific says that she was repeatedly
raped on her fairfax county middle
school campus
as a 12 year old and that she was
slashed with a knife
burned with a lighter and anally
penetrated
the law firm and mcauliffe's campaign
refused to comment on whether the law
firm still employs mcauliffe by the
deadline but mcauliffe reported income
apparently linked to the firm in 2021
after announcing his run for governor of
virginia on december 8 2020.
later advertisements from the firm for
mccullough fundraisers referred to
mcauliffe as a former
colleague um
the girl said she was afraid of having a
real name attached to the case because
one of her alleged tormentors had
threatened to kill her if she came
forward the mcauliffe-linked law firm is
seeking to have the case thrown out
because it was filed under a pseudonym
even though there's no dispute that the
school system knows who she is
um in a separate case and i can't read
this you got to go to daily wire read
the entire story but i'll read one more
example here it's a long story it's
important story um a girl alleged the
fcps administrators were told of an
unwanted sexual incident on a banned
trip
a school security officer told her there
was no point in seeking criminal charges
and that school
and the school gave an award to her
alleged abuser
hutton told the court that the school
system lost documentation showing his
investigation of the allegations in part
because it was not using a sexual
harassment allegation database that it
had promised to use pursuant to a
federal settlement in the other girl's
case
okay so if you're wondering
as i've been telling you about and again
you can go to
dailywire.com and see the entire story
there's another exclusive story as we're
doing
we're we're doing more uh
investigative pieces like this going out
and covering the stories that the
corporate media will not cover
these are this is real news real news
stories um and yet another reason why by
the way you should uh subscribe and
become a member and if you do that right
now go to dailywire.com subscribe and
use promo code real news uh you can
become a member for daily wire
that way
but
if you're wondering the reason why this
story is so important
aside from the fact that terry mcauliffe
is trying to become the governor
of virginia
at a time when they have a crisis in the
school system with a lack of
accountability and and this is someone
wants to become the governor who's
partly responsible for that lack of
accountability but the other thing that
makes this so important is that
as i've been telling you about the the
epidemic of sexual abuse in the school
system
uh
one of the reasons why we don't we don't
hear about it
because of guys like terry mcauliffe
and the people in the law firm
and the tricks that the school system
plays
not just in loudoun county
um
but across the country
you know i told you about that ap report
this was
every once in a while you know the
corporate media will do some real
investigation or report some real news
and so a few years ago the ap did a
report
about sexual abuse on public school
campuses
um by students on other students and
then you've got you've got teacher on
student sexual abuse which is a whole
other category
and there's thousands of such cases
and millions of vic literally millions
of victims of that but
the ap when they thought to look into it
a few years ago they found that in that
through the previous few years there had
been something like 17 000 cases
17 000
just in that few year window and just
student on student abuse
this stuff is very common very common
but we don't find out about it and uh
this is one of the reasons
all the different ways of
hiding it from the public
it's all about how they categorize these
incidents whether they choose to pursue
it and pursue legal action
um
and then you also have kids who like the
the girl in the story
are terrified to come forward i mean
think about
all these me too cases we heard about
and the question was well how did how
did
you know how did weinstein
manage to to do this for decades
without anyone coming really coming
forward and saying anything about it
um all of these all these victims all
these women who fell victim to it
i mean why did they come forward and say
anything why did it go on for decades
and the reason that we're given is that
well they were afraid to do it they felt
intimidated
they were worried about their hollywood
careers and so forth
well if that's the case for adults
what about 12 and 13 year old girls
in middle school and high school
who fall victim to this what and and um
they've got no one advocating for them
no one on their side
what hope do they have
so this is a major story this is a major
far-reaching story across the country
and uh here's the daily wire we're to
continue to pursue that and let you know
about it meanwhile
terry mcauliffe doesn't care about the
students who are raped
in loudoun county schools or any other
schools but the students themselves
certainly care and that's why hundreds
of students across loudoun county
we have some footage here staged a
walkout yesterday
because of loudoun county's cover-up of
of rapes of students multiple rapes of
students in the loudoun county school
system so you can see there and it
wasn't just one school there were
multiple schools where the kids walked
out
you see it here
well once again if you go to corporate
media for your news coverage you
probably didn't know this happened
so i want you to compare here we've got
hundreds of of of high school students
walking out because of of the sexual
abuse and rape of their fellow
classmates in school during school hours
so compare the media coverage of that
which was nil there was basically no
coverage
to the you know
the the few dozen weirdos who walked out
of netflix headquarters because
dave chappelle told some jokes that made
their tummies hurt
corporate media three weeks of coverage
for that and and still ongoing
i mean at the actual walkout at netflix
there were far more news cameras than
there were people walking out
but these kids
there's there's some local coverage and
then you're hearing about it from
conservative media but that's it
because this is simply not a
conversation that um
the corporate media wants to have
okay what else do we have here uh we'll
stay on the school board issue for a
minute
as we know it's not just a problem in
loudoun county here's a
minnesota school board which hasn't
stated new rules to uh stop those
domestic terrorist parents from reigning
terror
at uh at the school board meetings
here's here's jody sapp she's a school
board member
and here she is explaining the new rules
listen
i just want to remind everyone this is a
business meeting of the school board
it is not a meeting that belongs to the
public
each speaker is asked to state his or
her name and address for the record
failure to do so will result in an
individual
this is this is a meeting of the this is
not a meeting for the public
she says this meeting does not belong to
the public
no no jody
i got news for you the entire public
school system
is supposed to belong to the public
it is all public concern
all of
it that's why we call it the public
school system
but this is how they feel about it this
this is as parents this is simply not
your business
and if you're going to intrude in our
business
which is deciding what your kids are
going to be taught and how they're
treated
and whether they're um
and whether their sexual abuse will be
reported to police and all that if you
want to intrude in our business then you
got to follow our rules we're going to
make it as hard for you as possible
so here she is explaining the rules keep
keep playing
not being allowed to speak
john can you give us your name and
address please uh my name is john
wicklund i live in mankato could i get
your address please john um i'd rather
not since
you guys haven't already you can't speak
and i get so much uh property damage and
eggs and everything else
from
fun people and their friends
you need to give your address i live on
5th street
excuse me i live on fifth street it's
house numbered
[Music]
okay he gave his house thank you all
right
so are our kids safe
effective tonight the school board will
enforce the following guidelines
open forum participants are prohibited
from calling out or addressing any
individual school board
or school district staff member if this
occurs open forum will be closed and the
individual will not be allowed to
participate in future open forums
crowd noise or any sort of grandstanding
during open forum including applause
talking hollering or any outbursts will
result in open forum being closed
further beginning at the november first
school board meeting open forum
participation will be limited to those
individuals who wish to speak to an item
on the board agenda the board agenda is
always made available the thursday prior
to
our meetings and they are always on the
district website this this
evil
wench
they all look exactly the same by the
way
all of the little mini petty
bulbous tyrants that are running our
schools they all look exactly the same
they're they're like there's there's
like a uniform for these people
and they all in
they are so mad
that that parents are there
taking an interest in what they're doing
and trying to exert some actual
influence over the school system
and speaking up for their own kids they
are so angry about it
and that's why this
the response here has to be show up
show up get louder at the school board
meetings
keep showing up
more and more people keep doing exactly
what they don't want you to do
and don't stop
that's my one fear about um
this school board you know movement
right now
is that is that it will it will just
stop and fade away and go away
and we we have let's be honest we have a
history of that on the right uh not just
on the right but in our culture where uh
people generally have the memories of of
you know
field mice or something and they
couple days later it's like it never
happened you move on to the next thing
always always chasing the next shiny
object
um
there are a lot of things for us to
focus on in this culture a lot of
battle's worth having but this one has
to continue
because if two months from now we're
looking back on this and saying hey
remember when everyone was showing up to
those school board meetings that was
nice
if that's what we're saying two months
from now that none of this will will
matter
um we have to be relentless and
consistent
and that's been one of our big downfalls
i think the conservative movement
is a lack of consistency and not being
being nearly relentless enough
so keep coming keep getting keep
get louder and louder
the this is the lengths they'll go to
though
they
what jody there is saying is you have to
say your address
into the microphone
like the guy pointed out when he was
sitting there well you already know the
address you know the address there's no
reason why i have to say it
the only reason why the school board
would insist that you say it is to
intimidate you
that's the only reason they are trying
to get people hurt
and they they are they are indirectly
encouraging mobs to show up to these
people's houses that's what they're
doing
there's no other reason why you should
have to say it
and did she also say at another point
there that the no talking is allowed
i'm not exactly sure how you're supposed
to uh
voice your opinion if you're not allowed
to talk but i i don't know maybe draw
pictures
do a little pictionary sign language
would that be okay
all right
um let's see this is uh
some more information from the set of
the alec baldwin movie where that uh
tragic shooting occurred it says hannah
gutierrez reed the 24 year old armorer
who handled weapons on the set of alec
baldwin's rust was the subject of
numerous complaints on her previous film
just two months earlier after she
discharged weapons without warning an
infuriated star nicholas cage according
to a crew member who told the rap
stu um brahma
who who
served as key grip on the cage western
the old way this summer told the wrap
that gutierrez upset both cage and other
crew members on the montana production
by failing to follow basic gun safety
protocols like announcing the arrival
and usage of weapons on the set after
firing a gun near the casted crew for a
second time in three days without
warning
um cage yelled at her saying make an
announcement you just blew my effing
eardrums out before walking off the set
in a rage
and then according to other people on
the set they uh you know they said this
this by the way was her first
film where she had been the the armorer
and uh there were other alleged
incidents where she was walking around
with guns under her arm tucked under her
arms
holding guns got him tucked under her
arms
you know like she's like like they're a
bunch of i don't know pillows or books
or something and she's carrying them
around
and uh and then the barrels of the guns
as she's walking around end up pointing
at other people and that's another basic
rule of gun safety here is you can't
point the barrel at anybody
now
when you when you hear about
the armor on the set
who is supposed to be in charge of gun
safety and making sure that these guns
are safe and ready to be used in the
film
she's 24 years old
no experience apparently according to
what we're hearing here incompetent
um previous complaints
and uh according again according to
people on the set they said that it was
recommended by people on the on the set
that she she should be let go she's not
qualified for this
but then she ends up working on another
film right after that
and you start to wonder like how did
that happen why did she get this job
now to be clear
i don't think this is primarily her
fault i think that primarily this this
falls on alec baldwin he's the one who
was holding the weapon
he's the one who pulled the trigger
and he's the one who apparently failed
to check it which would have just taken
a second
uh just one once one second of your time
to check the weapon and save somebody's
life and he wasn't he didn't do that so
this primarily falls on him but
obviously as the armorer this was a
major failure on her part you wonder
how did she get this job
and um
and then i think back to
the new diversity rules that were put in
place by the academy awards
this was last year remember
they said if you want to be eligible for
an academy award
and anytime they're making a film in
hollywood they always want to be
eligible for an academy award there's a
whole bunch of
diversity
uh
boxes that you have to check
and among them
is this i'm reading now from the new
york times back up back when this when
this was first announced
it says at least one actor from an
underrepresented racial or ethnic group
must be cast in a significant role
the story must center on women lgbtq
people a racial or ethnic group or the
disabled at least 30 of the cast must be
actors from at least two of those four
underrepresented categories now this is
this is uh
these are this is st this is a category
standard a and so you have to check one
of the boxes from standard a
in order to be eligible for an academy
board but then there's also standard b
and you have to check a box here too and
it says
two or more department heads meaning
jobs like director cinematographer
composer must be female as lgbtq
disabled or part of an underrepresented
racial or ethnic group at least six
other crew members must be from an
underrepresented group
at least 30 of the film's crew must hail
from the four underrepresented groups
continually laid out in these guidelines
so it makes you wonder doesn't
it was this a matter of box checking
on the part of the producers of this
film rust
it could have also been nepotism
apparently this this woman's father has
ties with hollywood has been in
hollywood for a long time
could be both
but this would be an interesting
question to explore wouldn't it
it's just we know the corporate media
won't explore it
is was that a factor
this this is this is far from a stretch
we know the academy award less than a
year ago imposed rules
arbitrary rules saying that you have to
have a certain number of females on the
crew
and then shortly after that
an apparently unqualified incompetent
way too young for the job female was
hired and someone is dead
you don't have to stretch very hard to
connect those two things potentially
of course i don't really know what what
this what went into this decision-making
process here
it would require people in the media
with connections here to to follow this
trail
follow the breadcrumbs and they're not
going to do it
but it's definitely a question worth
asking
and
whether these two issues are tied in
this case or not
it still underscores how absurd rules
like these are
because what whatever the reason is
for this woman to get the job that she
got
it's pretty clear she wasn't qualified
for it
and it's also clear that um the only
thing that should matter
when someone is applying for a job is
whether or not they are qualified for it
whether they can do the job
what they look like their demographics
whether whether they belong to an
underrepresented group
i'm not exactly sure how you can call
women an underrepresented group when
they're you know more than half of the
world population
but none of that should should matter at
all or should factory
okay this is from the new york post it
says a fitness model has been slammed
online after she shared a series of
photos posing in front of her father's
coffin
described by commentators as sick vile
and disgusting jane rivera from miami
florida is a tick-tock star who's gained
popularity through her fashion travel in
swimwear posts last week she took to
instagram revealing her father a veteran
had passed away
and um and then here she is in the
pictures we can see her
posing
in one picture there so she's right in
front of her dad's coffin in one picture
she's actually i guess showing off her
butt right in front of her dead father
and there were multiple pictures but
she's now now because of the reaction
she's taken down her instagram page
is how out of touch and what a bubble
these influencers live in
where she posed for these selfies
in front of her dead father and put him
online and was not expecting anybody
would be upset about it
people were upset she took down her
whole her whole page
if you see this kind of thing and we see
this a lot
um
in influencers or want to be influencers
reacting to tragic situations by you
know they want to get the selfie they
want to they want to they want to mine
it for clicks and likes and all of that
and we we see this and it's easy enough
to say ah it's just silly superficial
stupid people which of course that's
part of it
but there's a real i mean there's
there's something happening
psychologically to people
and young people especially who grow up
online
and they become so dependent
on affirmation online
that they really become sociopaths this
is this is sociopathic behavior
to respond to your father's death that
way i mean for that to even be something
that enters your mind but here's my
father laying in a cough and he's dead
let me get a quick self this will be
great for instagram
there's a real mental sickness
uh
that is is present in a lot of people's
minds i think and that's pretty clear
all right let's get now to reading the
comments
who's rocking polka dots with our shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
matthew st peter says i take comfort in
knowing that matt walsh would never put
the life of a dog above the life of a
human
especially after his dog ate his remote
yeah you know if i was going to put any
animal life over human life it wouldn't
be dogs that i think that's that's the
thing i probably wouldn't do it for any
animal life but dogs would not
wouldn't make the cut derrick woods says
i'm out i'm outraged about the cruelty
to the unborn and to the cruelty of
man's best friend
both can be true and both should be
investigated charged and led to the jail
time of all those involved
jason trimble says jesus specifically
commands us to love our neighbor as
ourself who is our neighbor our family
friends and those who interact we
interact with in life even our enemies
not our dogs
ozzy says i unfortunately went through
an alphabet squad phase i was thinking
about becoming trans
it almost came out to my parents but
then i discovered your channel and
helped me realize how lost i was thank
you so much for speaking the truth well
thanks for thanks for telling me that
ozzie that's uh
that does actually
make me feel like there might be a small
bit of difference being made here
um and i'm glad that you were able to
see the light on that and it's it's
it's interesting that you say that
though because
we're told that that never happens i
mean you said that you were
feeling a little bit confused and you
were thinking about becoming trans
and we're told that that that's not how
it works right anyone who identifies as
trans is because they've like they've
known it ever since they were a young
child it's deeply ingrained within them
how many times have you heard someone
say oh it's not like anyone would wake
up one day and just decide to be trans
but as you attest to that is sort of
what happens actually
pesky says mr walsh i humbly point out
that i am indeed the young man who
confronted ben shapiro in the name of
the sweet baby gang i am deeply honored
to have served you and your our fellow
sweet babies in our quest for world
domination and i will continue to carry
the sbg torch via my own youtube channel
our voices will not be silenced
so you put the little plug for your
youtube channel i respect that hustle
and i would want all
everyone in the sweet baby gang to do
the same when given the opportunity and
i appreciate your service
and i would encourage
you at any af event for with other daily
wire
personalities
don't don't be afraid to show up
with your sweet baby gang flag flying
high
they they all love it trust me
they won't tell you but they do deep
down their hearts
um ian says here we go again on this
channel
you know i'm getting sick and tired of
getting backslapped by conservatives
because of my love of animals and how
much i decry the abominations done to
them
if that's how matt and michael feel then
i don't need to be this kind of
conservative either as a catholic i hold
to be
both to be in the same regard
dogs and humans if not the same value
pulling my support from the dw now that
i've heard matt's take
mistreatment some dogs are mistreated
that's a gross understatement if ever i
heard one and they just disdain from the
dw hosts over this and the outcries
while they fall back on their pro-life
arguments are revolting
i am pro-life all the way and i feel
horror in equal measure
uh b-rob says i'd say i value babies
over puppies but i definitely value dogs
over adult people
dr lechter says matt is a
self-proclaimed animal lover i would
have to slightly disagree with your
thoughts about people versus dogs my
only argument is that in my past chosen
profession all i've seen is brutality
violence and aggression inflicted on
people by other people mostly the
violence i've seen is on weaker people
being preyed upon by bullies and
aggressive thugs would you have an issue
with using death row inmates and or
child rapists as the guinea pigs after
all we're trying to develop things for
humans
uh let's use the ones that have no
desire to be in civilized society we're
gonna respond to all this in a second
hold on uh lateralist says every life
matters it's not always about us humans
nancy says i value dogs and people
equally another comment says it's a lot
easier to hate humans than it is to hate
dogs liking animals isn't the problem
people being less likable than animals
is the problem
richard says you're very wrong about
this matt you really don't get it very
disappointed in you that you failed to
capture this moment torturing dogs is
eagle evil
pm says dogs are better than most people
i have no problem valuing them more
jared says puppies are better than
humans just saying
good morning toast says no it's not a
sickness dogs are nicer than people
simple as that and don says i so value
the life of dogs over most people
because people are inherently evil
dogs are trained to be violent which
falls back on a-hole people who train
the dogs so that's why people suck and
dogs rule okay
a lot of comments in that vein telling
me that i'm wrong uh for for daring to
suggest that people have more value than
dogs and i'm gonna respond to all of
those comments in the daily cancellation
which will be right after this you know
if you're one of those old fogies like
myself with uh boxes of old tapes and
films and uh you know photo albums and
everything just sitting around
collecting dust
potentially depending on where they're
stored you know they could be damaged if
that's the case for you then you've got
to check out legacy box legacy box is
your chance to have aging tapes films
and photos digitally preserved so the
ability to relive your family history is
never lost because of a leaky pipe or
summer days that make your attic hot
enough to melt tapes plus this week
legacy box is offering 40 off at
legacybox.com walsh so you can start
future proofing your past today with
legacy box you can reclaim all the
prices footage you haven't been able to
see in years the service could not be
simpler you just use their kit to safely
send the moments you want preserved
their team will create a digital archive
by hand right here in the usa and
they'll return everything back to you
and
it's as simple as that you put
everything in the box send it to them
they send you back
um what you want whether it's
you get everything on the cloud you get
it on a thumb drive on a dvd whatever
you want it's very very easy and simple
for you and also cheap and quick what is
there not to love visit legacybox.com
walsh to take advantage of this limited
time offer for 40 off take advantage of
this exclusive offer today and then use
their kit whenever you're ready that's
legacy box dot com slash walls to say 40
off legacy box dot com slash walsh you
know when it comes to the facts the
daily wires newest podcast morning wire
has never has a never-ending supply not
only has it been topping the apple and
spotify charts since its release it's
the only daily podcast that values your
time and the truth and while we're
working overtime to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending towards number
one so subscribe and start listening now
to morningwire on applespotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts and
leave a five star review if you like
what you hear now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to cancel the people
who wrote those comments that i just
read and many others in the audience who
wrote similar comments or sent messages
in the same vein
unfortunately you're all
canceled today your time has come so
just take your medicine
don't complain about it
now if you missed the show yesterday uh
you're canceled for that also for
missing the show of course but let's
back up for a moment yesterday we
discussed the backlash that anthony
fauci is facing after it was reported
that the um niaid under fauci's
leadership funded a study in which
beagle puppies were drugged infected
with parasites and sometimes had their
vocal cords cut to prevent them from
barking this was all done ostensibly to
help develop medicine and medical
treatments for humans
now there's nothing wrong in principle
with experimenting on animals in order
to develop treatments for people
but this particular experiment seems to
be gratuitous not to mention from what
i've read mostly useless since beagles
don't make good analogs for humans in a
laboratory setting
but that's not the only controversial
quote unquote study that fauci has been
linked to his organization has also
funded an experiment where aborted
babies were chopped into pieces and
their parts were grafted onto mice
now as i pointed out
the outrage over the experiments on
puppies has been significantly greater
than the outrage over the experiments on
human children
i argue that this discrepancy is a
symptom of our culture's pseudo-pagan
animal worship
we tend to value animal life especially
dog life over human life
and that's a bad thing
it's not that dogs have no value it's
just that human life has infinitely
greater value
that was the argument i presented and as
you just heard it has not been greeted
with wide approval or a claim there are
lots of people even on the right who
will openly profess that they value dogs
over their fellow human beings
now i find this point of view totally
perverse
and though i shouldn't have to explain
why apparently i do
so let me try to lay out the case now a
few points to take into consideration
first of all if human life does not have
special unique inherent value
then there is no point to any of the
arguments we have or any of the issues
we care about or the things we fight for
there's no point to life at all in fact
at least not much of a point
the whole basis for the doctrine of
human rights for example
is that human beings have inherent worth
and value above that of a beast or a bug
there's a reason why we would say that
it's an infringement on a child's rights
if you uh you know feed them out of a
dog bowl on the floor and lock them in a
crate
and make them go to the bathroom out in
the out in the yard yeah we
wouldn't say that it's an infringement
on a dog's rights to do that
the reason is that children are human
and as a humans they have unique dignity
which carries with it rights and
liberties
if you don't believe that then again
there's no basis for your conservatism
or even your liberalism or any ideology
except absolute suicidal nihilism
second
the good thing is that even though
people say they think dogs have equal
value or more value
most of those people don't really
believe it
going back to the kid in the crate
situation i'm guessing that every single
person who left an angry comment on my
show yesterday would react with utter
shock and horror at a child being
treated like a dog
but they would not react that way to a
dog being treated like a dog
further i'm betting that all of them if
they were driving along and you know saw
a dead dog on the side of the road
they'd feel sad about it yeah
but if they saw a dead human
they'd react quite a bit stronger to it
and further i'm betting i'm hoping
that if you know a woman and a dog were
trapped in a burning building and they
could only save one
all of them would save the woman
i'm betting and hoping that none of them
would say oh sorry lady i got to take
this dog out and leave her to burn to
death
so these examples only show that people
think they value dogs and people the
same but they're confused
you know it's good that they're confused
because if they actually did value them
the same
they'd be full on psychopaths
it might be said that the definition of
a psychopath the literal definition
could be a person who treats other
people like dogs
but i don't think that most of this dog
worship is born from psychopathy
necessarily i think it's born partly for
moral degradation yes but also largely
from confusion
third part of the source of that
confusion
is this half-baked idea that many people
have as expressed in some of those
comments
that dogs are somehow morally superior
to humans because humans do a lot of
terrible things
while dogs never do terrible things
only that's not true of course i mean
dogs maul children they kill people
further down the scale of atrocities
they chew your couch and pillows and
shoes
the difference is that you don't hold
dogs morally responsible for that
you would never say that a dog who does
something bad even as bad as killing a
child
has committed evil and why because you
recognize that dogs are incapable of
making moral choices they're not
assessing a variety of options and
choosing one based on which is the most
ethical or moral
and that's correct
that's how they get off the hook when
they do bad things that's why
you get to always blame the owner when a
pit bull sends someone to the hospital
you always say there's no bad dogs
there's only bad owners
fine
but if you're letting dogs off the hook
for bad actions
because they can't make moral choices
then you can't very well give them
credit for good actions
you can't describe traits like courage
and selflessness to dogs if you're not
also going to ascribe traits like evil
selfishness cowardice to them in equal
measure
dogs act on instinct
they act on training
they're not moral beings
so yes humans do terrible stuff that
dogs don't do
humans also do incredible courageous
beautiful selfless loving things that
dogs don't do
humans are complex conscious moral
creatures dogs are not
fourth but this is really what it comes
down to i think
humans are complex like i just said
complicated difficult
this is why we often prefer pets pets
are easy they're not complicated they
don't ask much of you
they have needs but their needs are
simple
their lives revolve around us
they give us what we need emotionally
without asking for anything in return
this isn't because of any moral virtue
on their part it's just because they're
animals
ice cream can give you what you want
without asking anything in return too so
can a tree if it's hot out and you want
shade
but it would be
it would be bizarre to say i value this
tree more than the human race because it
provides better shade than people
trees do what trees do
dogs do what dogs do
it's good to be grateful for both
and to value the things they do and what
they give you but to value them above
people or on the level with people
is deeply confused
and again i i'm being generous by
calling it confused
the other option is that it's totally
morally depraved and a sign that you're
a burgeoning serial killer
but whichever is the case
either way
you're still today i have to say
unfortunately
canceled
you and your dog
he's getting lumped in with this also
and that'll do do it for us today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producer is mathis glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show with terry
mcauliffe running a rough race in
virginia joe biden steps in to deliver a
disgusting smear against glenn younkin
plus democrats continue to struggle over
their spending package as inflation sets
in that's today on the bench prayer show
give it a listen